hi i'm madison eisman and i play lennon
and allison grant hi i'm brianne chu and
i play margot gilbert hey i'm sebastian
russo and i play johnny hi i'm ezekiel
goodman and i play dylan scanlon hi i'm
ashley moore and i play riley thacker we
are the cast of i know what you did last
summer and we are here with buzzfeed to
play a game of who's who
[Music]
okay number one who's most likely to
pull a prank on set three two one ashley
as ashley
that was crazy how we all sat out like
me
we just loved to scare brienne
rianne was the one that we always liked
to
to get so she was the one getting
pranked
very skittish so it's fun to to scare me
because i have a very dramatic reaction
like falling out on the floor like
rolled over
like there wasn't one prankster i feel
like we all collectively love to
make brands yeah the better question is
who was the pranky and that was me
everyone would have had the same answer
i accurate okay who's most likely to
survive until the end of a horror movie
brianne brienne ran
i say brienne 100 yeah briana 100
madison are you kidding me i never in a
million years gonna pick myself
i don't know why what do you guys think
you're the smartest i feel like you
would be able to figure out an escape
plan the best you would definitely be
scared but you would have the best
survival skills yeah
this is what we're going to do
guys guys a single like okay she gets
scared one time and she starts screaming
and then everybody finds her and she
died that speaks to her her overall
cautiousness you're very efficient
brienne i think that you'd be very
direct about that that's my argument you
want to be like let's go into the
basement you'd be like i'm leaving this
house right now you either come with me
or you don't
explore but i'm not sticking around for
this who's most likely to get killed off
in a horror movie first me
i'm gonna go with zee because he picked
himself i'm gonna go with zeke as well
we agree with you zeke yeah we are crazy
can you die
because i'd be like i'd be like oh this
basement is dark
yeah you're curious and i i think that
i'm can be very trusting to a fault
sometimes it'd be like oh i just want to
like the guy like leatherface would like
come up to me and i'd be like hey buddy
you want to chat
yeah what are you doing okay
okay good follow me
okay who would you trust to keep a deep
dark secret ashley brienne be like bree
or madison i feel like everyone here is
somewhat trustworthy though like i would
trust you all with one piece of
yeah who's most like their character
i feel like this is hard because we
like
all of our characters have like these
flaws pushed to the front do you know
what i mean what is the only one that i
would actually want to be friends with
exactly same like riley
that's true that's true
most honest and like
like she's pure you know and so i feel
like that's you ashley you know what i
agree but i don't deal drugs
who's most likely to start a true crime
okay then zeke for sure for sure it's
zeke
for sure no question
what i would choose myself do any of you
listen guys it's zeke are you kidding
this is so obvious
for sure zeke every day what honestly
maybe yeah
i would feel lucky like if brienne had
me on for like an episode but like
but like i feel like
i feel like you'd like be gathering like
cereal style like i'm gathering this
piece of evidence
you know what i mean like you think that
you'd be so good at that who's least
like their character you brianne
i mean
yeah you are instagram batty but not in
the way margot is yes
yeah yeah like you're not vapid and like
like accidentally vapid like i think
you're pretty
through and through cargo's
intentionally vapid yeah intentionally
no you're right you're right yeah
honestly that is such a relief that you
guys picked me because um margo's not
perfect by any means i don't necessarily
want to be her she has a lot of sadness
she's carrying around in darkness so
yeah who's most likely to go all out for
halloween madison yeah
um
madison you don't you throw like
halloween parties and dress up and stuff
i do that on just like normal days
though
i could see you and spencer being like a
costume together like yeah like two
years ago whatever the year was before
the pandemic spencer and i went out as
dick in a box from snl and won so many
costume competitions
okay i'll take that one who's most
likely to laugh bring character on set
oh madison madison madison madison
madison
i made bill upset uh a couple times
because i could not hold it together in
some scenes we had but he's just such a
nice person and i just had to laugh you
would have like tears streaming down
your face in an emotional scene and
you'd be like hold on one second
like go it'd be awesome
oh my god who's most likely to host a
horror movie marathon madison she loves
horror movies yeah
yeah
or brianne we could host a really great
horror movie marathon yeah both of you
too as a duo who's most likely to nail a
scream scene on the first take you could
just like touch bri you can just talk
like
it's almost like a button you know it's
like that yeah
and so i don't know
i i think it's because i grew up with um
three sisters and so you know if you
wanted to be heard you had to be loud um
or you just scream and get someone's
attention so it's kind of like innate in
me now who's best at doing impressions
of their cast members i did a really
good bill hack you do and you gave me
johnny cash yeah johnny cash our cast
member johnny cash who is most likely to
be caught napping between scenes ashley
or brienne i feel like brienne you can
go to sleep anywhere yeah
i go to my trailer and yeah
okay
just like yeah if i'm tired i'm going to
bed we did it
thanks so much buzzfeed be sure to catch
all of us on i know what you did last
summer streaming on amazon prime video
[Music]
you